what's up everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
with my friend and the author of a new
book called perennial seller what do we
got here the art of making and marketing
work that last mr. Ryan holiday back on
the show how you doing Ryan I'm doing
great it's good to talk to you again man
so so you know I met Ryan painting in
New York when I was just about to launch
my book your one word and he was telling
me what's your goal is your goal to make
the New York Times bestseller list or is
your goal to have something that kind of
lasts and like you know I would love to
make a list but really I want people to
read the book I wanted to be evergreen
content that in 10 20 40 years it's
still applicable and eager and he said
you told me that's the other thing
that's the right thing he's like yes
it's great to hit the list but you won't
work that lasts and here's now his book
on how to create and market work that
lasts oh I love it we're relying on the
vision let me let me put the book here
some people can see it next to my new
one coming out tell me tell me in my
audience just like quick story behind
the book what it's about what you hope
people get from reading it well so it's
actually really interesting if you look
at the New York Times bestseller list
which the average person thing sort of
reflects you know the best-selling books
in the country each week and you go to
the fine print it actually says we
exclude so-called perennial sellers and
the reason they do that is you know the
number one best-selling book in the
country every week would be the Bible
and then it would probably be Harry
Potter and then this secret and a bunch
of other books right some of these books
are great some of these books are not
great but the truth is the vast majority
of sales in the book industry some
people have estimated as high as 90% our
books that are more than a year old we
call this the back list right and even
even on the average website like if I
bet if I looked at your archive and then
I was like okay what did the most
traffic in a given week or a given month
it wouldn't be your brand-new stuff it'd
be things that you made a year ago or
one year or two years ago or even five
or six years ago and so we have this
bias towards newness because that's
what's exciting but the truth is the
vast majority of revenue and interest
comes from the established the so called
classics it's interesting right in the
startup world we don't we don't look at
the startups that have been around the
longest or that have made the most money
we look at the startups that have
raised the most money right we want to
look at who's announcing a new
fundraising round on TechCrunch we don't
go hey look who's doing really well and
so what I was trying to do in the book
was really sort of least Center people
on the things that matter it's like we
all claim that we want to make a company
or a video or content or a book that's
gonna stand the test of time and then we
measure ourselves against these you know
we measure ourselves against the second
hand rather than you know the the month
or the years and so I'm trying to get
people to sort of reset their
expectations and think about it more in
the long term because because that's
where I think meaningful work is done
got it so so if we look at if you went
to New York Times list and found
whatever was number one right now
yeah let's based on the past week sales
yeah where do you think that book would
rank in the actual like book sold this
week well it's it totally depends right
I mean even even the New York Times
bestseller list is filtering you know it
heavily weighs independent retail versus
say Costco or Walmart sales it heavily
weighs physical stores over Amazon and
and then it also discounts book orders
right so if you're if you have a huge
audience and you were doing an event in
front of 2,000 people tomorrow and they
each bought a copy at your event those
copies wouldn't count for the sales on
the list and so there's all these
criteria that make the thing that looks
like it's popular right now actually
artificially seem artificially more
popular than it actually is and so right
even think about it this way right a
book that sells 10,000 copies in a
single week is considered a best-seller
but a book that sells 20,000 copies over
the course of a year obviously sold
twice as many copies but it might not
ever appear on one of those bestseller
lists so it's really important to know
that most popular or bestseller does not
mean it was the bestseller over a longer
period of time it doesn't mean that it's
going to continue to sell it just means
in that sort of tiny snapshot of time it
hit some artificial criteria and
look Star Wars gets beaten at the box
office its opening weekend by Smokey and
the Bandit
but clearly Star Wars wins over the long
term because one of the most valuable
franchises you know in the history of
art and so I'm pushing people more
towards that right so so I'm just
curious to the relative difference like
if if I if you sell ten thousand copies
of book you're gonna hit the best of a
list on average yeah probably it's gonna
depend on the criteria it's gonna depend
on what what category your book is in it
also depends on who else came out that
given week so write your book if you
have the unfortunate timing to be
released you know the week before
Christmas
your a lot of other books are gonna sell
a lot more copies whereas if that same
book was released in June you might
debut at number one so you might not hit
the list one-month debut at number one a
different month and so my point is
because these things are so arbitrary
and again such a small measurement of
time and sales they really have no
bearing on whether that work is going to
continue to be relevant over like who
cares whether the great gatsby came out
as was a best-seller and I I don't
remember how much money the shawshank
redemption' made its opening weekend at
the box office what matters is that it's
it's still good that it's still relevant
and that people are still talking about
it right do you know how many copies of
the Bible or Harry Potter or you know
4-hour workweek are sold on a consistent
basis now there would be many many
thousands of copies per week and often
they would be at places that don't don't
even the New York Times bestseller list
it's not as if there's some central
database that records all book sales
right if some you can buy the Bible at a
gas station right they don't report to
the New York Times bestseller list if
you grab that Bible out of the the
drawer of your hotel room and you take
it home with them does that count as a
sale right I'm an advisor to a start-up
that's called vinyl meet they're the
world's largest vinyl record club
they've about 30,000 customers who get
one vinyl record every month right
so whatever vinyl record that Club buys
for that month
is the number one best-selling album in
the country that month but it doesn't
appear on the Billboard charts because
the Billboard charts don't recognize
vinyl me as being a retailer of units so
you know the number one album in the
country
for vinyl might might have reported
sales of four or five thousand copies
meanwhile you have this this up this
jazz reissue from 1962 that vaio me
chose that sold 30,000 units and it's
not reporting so so I again these things
are very obviously when you put out a
book you put out a book the first thing
you do is go in my best seller am i
hitting the like we do care about these
things it's very natural but it's just
important that you're not prioritizing
that over the things that really matter
which is a year from now is this thing
still working for people and are they
still talking about it right I mean I
love the idea I'm totally aligned with
it it's one of the main reasons why I
make the content I make on youtube I
don't cover news topics I don't go heavy
on vlogs because it's it's a really like
short spike yeah and then it falls off
where I want the content I make the
rules for success this video you know to
last in ten years it's still applicable
like I want it's why I was slow to get
into snapchat and Instagram because I
don't like the expiring stories I want
the work I'm making to really last and
live forever and YouTube is a great
content platform for that well no I
think that's a good way of thinking
about it's like look making a making a
video is a certain amount of work either
way right so if you're making videos
that are responding to a breaking news
story that's that's a certain amount of
work and then if you're making a video
about ten rules for success that's a
certain amount of work but what what
work is likely to continue to pay
dividends over time right if you're
reporting on this breaking news and then
it turns out that the breaking news was
incorrect no one is gonna watch that
video anymore
but people are still gonna care about
the rules of success from Tim Ferriss or
Bill Gates or Elon Musk because those
are huge people who have whose success
isn't going anywhere anytime soon and so
that
like Jeff Bezos who's the founder of
Amazon is this great Roy says focus on
the things that don't change right like
he's like people always want cheap stuff
and they always want it right away and
so he's like those are the core
principles of Amazon not hey fidget
spinners are really popular right now
let's sell more fidget spinners you know
what I mean got guys we also have two
top ten rules for Ryan holiday that you
need to go check out the great videos
that will last forever timeless wisdom
so the book is dividing you got a seam
in your title like making the work and
then mark it into work so let's let's
divide that up one so I want to make
something I want to make a video when I
make a book I want to make a record what
are some of the things I need to keep in
mind to make something that will last so
I see it as like two consecutive
marathons right making it as marathon
number one in marketing it is marathon
number two you've got it and you've got
to finish both and you've got to have
enough energy to finish both so the
first thing is like look if you want to
make something that lasts you have to
you have to put in the work and you have
to put in the ideas that are likely to
make it work right one of the examples I
have in perennial seller it's a book you
know there's a there's a great authors
named Guy Kawasaki he wrote a book
called enchantment and enchantment was
about sort of creating these dazzling
you know love affairs with your
customers and that's a great book it's
sold for many many years and then a few
years ago you did a book called what the
Plus Google+ for the rest of us right
and it was like a guide to Google+ well
one obviously took a lot more time than
the other and and and the and one was a
lot more timely than the other and so
which one is likely to continue to be
selling a year from now or 10 years from
now enchantment has captured something
timeless a book about Google+ certainly
hasn't and so I think oftentimes people
are going oh crypto currencies are
really popular right now I want to make
something about that or everyone's upset
about Donald Trump I want to talk about
that right and so they're always
thinking about what's happening right
now
and they're not asking themselves is
this underlying factor still going to be
true in the future right and then I
think you have to go did I actually put
in the work
did I make something that I asked myself
the tough questions that I put in the
you know Elon Musk is compared I think
he said starting a company is like
eating glass and staring into the abyss
okay it's really hard right and so if
you did this you know on an all-nighter
if you if you if you rushed through it
because you thought it was gonna be easy
or fast I I'm almost certain that what
you've made isn't going to have the
substance and the quality there's not
going to be the there there that you
need to really endure like what's so
great about star wars for instance is
not that it's this just that it's a
futuristic movie filled with special
effects right it's that it's the hero's
journey it's the timeless story of Luke
Skywalker Luke Skywalker story is the
same story as the story of Jesus Christ
or the story of Odysseus or the story of
Gilgamesh right it's an epic journey of
one character who we follow and it is
tested and and all these things right so
when we're making whatever we're making
whether it's a startup or whether it's a
it's a book or a video did we put in the
ingredients that are necessary for this
thing to endure and and that's that's
much harder to do than people think
marketing is fun and sexy often but the
work is where the heavy lifting is done
you don't like to think of it as like a
Mike reading work that I want to show my
grandkids yes is this proud of anyone
away yeah aim is timeless yes no no
that's it that's a great way to think
about it I mean here's a it and it
applies to every part of the creative
process right so I don't know if you've
heard of this company wealth front right
it's a it's a big it's a big wealth
management startup you put some of your
retirement money in there and then it
has this algorithm that invests it in in
in different index funds so it it's a
great company I use it myself
their original name was could shingle
write like would you put your retirement
money in a company called cachinga like
of course not right and so even the name
and the title on a book the cover the
logo like you're wearing that you're
you've got the logo on your sweatshirt
right there these all all the branding
in the feet and every
in your building around the product has
to be to the highest quality and you
can't settle and if you have partners
whether it's a publisher or a business
partner and investor you can't let them
rush you and get you to compromises you
have to fulfill that creative vision
that that it's gonna stand the test of
time so so it kind of transitions into
the marketing side so we've created this
great product that we're proud of we
want to show our grandkids you know I
want my grandkids to watch this
interview with Ryan holiday how am I
going to market it for the next 60 years
you know so that happens well so I think
people sort of fall into two camps on
the one hand there's like the the
natural marketers who want to like rush
through the creative phase to get to the
sales part because that's what they're
really good at and then you have other
people who love the creative process and
then they think marketing is somehow
like scammy
or it's beneath them you know and both
attitudes are really problematic so I
think what I want to tell the people who
love the creative side of things is look
the world is not a meritocracy there are
there are plenty of brilliant genius
works of art that have been completely
forgotten or that we're never even seen
right so if you know if you build it
they will not come you have to make them
come you know you have to give to bring
them to the work and so I want people to
be willing to treat the marketing side
of things with the same amount of energy
and creativity that they that they
treated the the writing or the editing
or the the building and the programming
and so from from a marketing standpoint
what I'm thinking is okay
the end of the day people read things or
watch things because other people told
them it was good so let me make sure
that my marketing is getting this work
in the hands of those early adopters so
they're passing it to the people that I
I need to see it does that make sense
yeah so so like tactical so yeah I took
my book as an example right it's coming
out December 6 not to Russo success
guys he's he's at the top two books of
2017 right there so so okay so like how
do I
that's what advices Ryan holiday hats
and that book well so number one thing
you're already in a position to succeed
because you've built a huge platform
right how many people want a platform
but they haven't put in the time or the
years to build one so when they go to
launch something they actually have
those group of hardcore fans who are
interested right so my first like the
first 50% of my marketing for you would
be like how do we take advantage of this
platform and I don't mean that in a bad
way I mean how do we get the people who
have already said I'm a big Evan
Carmichael fan how do we get the people
who watched your videos millions of
times to check out this book right so
probably what I'm gonna be thinking
about is like how do I make this accept
how do I make this cheap and accessible
how do i how do i market to them over
email how do i create compelling offers
of bonus material to get like your the
people who subscribe to your YouTube
channel they're the people who are most
likely going to be the first readers of
this book and then they're gonna
recommend it to other people right so
that's gonna be a huge percentage of my
time and then the second part of the
things is like okay what podcasts can I
go on what articles can I write what
extra videos can I make how can I take
the content that's in this book that's
clearly proven to work and get it in
front of people like one of the
interesting things on books is like it's
almost crazy that anyone buys books
right like you're like hey here's this
book it costs $20 you don't know what's
in it until after you've already bought
it and it will take you a week of your
life to decide whether you like it or
not right who's like who does that
that's crazy so so often times I try to
be as generous as I would say that of my
books even perennial seller huge chunks
of it are available online even in this
interview I'm walking people through
step by step almost everything that's in
the book because they look it's only
once you've you go oh hey I agree with
that or oh hey I think there's gonna be
value in that that you decide to give
someone your hard-earned money got it
now bringing this to the YouTube world I
get the YouTube world a lot better than
the book world that yeah I know you were
a master of uh I've
I've always focused on the content here
and YouTube becomes its own distribution
channel for you and I've done
collaborations with channels that are
way bigger than mine and we'll get a
spike like right now we're getting you
know upwards of 2,000 subscribers every
day about to sign up for the channel
sure if I do a club with somebody who's
bigger than me I might get a quick spike
to like four thousand for that day and
then it and then it quickly drops back
down sure you know 50 cent has tweeted
me out and Floyd Mayweather's shared on
Facebook and a bunch of people that
we've covered have then shared it to
their audience and again like quick hit
spike and then back down to what I
default to and tell me my thinking is
wrong okay what IV fault - is it takes
so much time and work to get the
attention of those people if I was
trying to do it like outwardly like hey
can you please you know listen to me
ears write work together versus if I
just keep creating great content I'm
gonna keep getting two thousand three
thousand like just keep getting that
daily subscriber growth so I ID fault to
just make better content and the YouTube
platform and community like it takes
care of itself
yes it's not wrong no I don't think it's
wrong as a writer I think that often the
best way I can get attention for my
books is to write really good articles
write articles that are because what's
different online is that the content and
marketing are fused together because
it's so easy to share right like if I
was if you if your YouTube videos were
were for sale I don't think just making
more videos would be marketing right
right but the fact that the videos are
so easy to share on social media you can
embed them you know search engine you
know search engine is gonna drive
traffic etc it's it's different right
but I think when you're selling
something then you've got to be more
active in the marketing because there's
you're asking people to do something
that's more difficult so in your case
what you're doing is you're constantly
building up and building up the platform
which you monetize occasionally with a
product or you know with ads but but
your product online is your marketing so
I think that makes total sense John it's
okay
well it's I've that's what I've been
preaching in so what has been working
okay it's not just doing it once but
it's doing it all the time like you've
built a machine so you're you're you're
always growing maybe if you were if
you'd started your channel yesterday
more collaborations would be a way to
build your base right so so let's go
down the funnel so you know I've gone a
buckets around success entrepreneurship
I have a platform in for other authors
they're gonna have their platform may
not be as big but they have their own
whatever Twitter following YouTube great
we're gonna market to them that other
50% podcast interviews what do you
recommend in terms of the strategy and
the outreach to say okay here's a book
about entrepreneurship yeah Who am I
gonna reach out to what does high pitch
gonna be how do I make it so that I
maximize the effort that's coming out
well so I I get a question a lot from
creators where they go like look I'm
starting a blog about fitness or I'm
starting a blog about entrepreneurship
or whatever it is they go like what
influencers should I reach out to and
and my answer is always if you don't
know then you haven't done your research
to jut to even justify making this web
you know what I mean like you I imagine
you know all the influencers in your
space that you want to reach out to
because you live and breathe this stuff
right and so it can't like if you don't
know your own space well enough to know
who the right influencers are I would
say you're you're making a huge mistake
so I really want people to know like who
are the movers and shakers and have you
studied the the space that you're in to
really see who who makes a difference
right like it's like if you're a
comedian and you didn't know that The
Tonight Show is where you go to break
out as a comedian it's like dude what
are you doing and so so you have to live
and breathe your space to the point
where you know who all those influencers
are and you shouldn't just be
cultivating relationships with them
because they can help you sell your
stuff you should know those people in
your space because they're your peer
group right James alternators talked
about the importance of having a scene
right like who are who are the people
that are doing really similar work as
you and how are you pushing each other
how are you making each other better how
are you helping each other it can it can
go that way and I would say the
thing I would think about is like don't
just think about it as like what can
these people do for me one of the best
ways to develop relationships and to
grow your work and to get fans is to is
to be a supporter of other people right
I built my platform as an author an
email list that's now about 85,000
people by recommending other authors
right I started a reading list where I
recommend books it's just if you go to
my websites Bryan Holaday dotnet slash
reading list and it's it's just
recommendations of books that I really
like and so I've met hundreds if not
thousands of authors over the last 10
years that I've done this as well as
contacts and publishers agents editors
etc because I've been a champion of
other people's work and I think your
channel is a testament to that too
very few of the videos are about you
they're all about other people and how
your you translated their work and
brought it to a larger audience yeah I
think about in my youtube experience the
first two collaborations I did with kind
of bigger channels and me at the time
were Tim Schmoyer and Derral Eve's and
they both have like how to YouTube kinds
of channels and I was already a fan of
their channel and I already subscribed
and I knew their content I think if you
are a fan already and you know you know
you're already aligned like you like
them because you like their message and
they're more likely to want to do some
kind of work with you yeah I mean so I
get an email probably once a day and
it's like dear sir I'm so-and-so I would
like to suggest a guest post on your
website I'm ready man it's like I've
never done a guest post on my website
ever so I know by nature of sending me
this email that you're not a fan right
know what I mean and so so it's like if
you don't know their people's work it's
really hard for you to fake that and
they can see through it immediately and
so like don't look for these hacks and
tricks like do the work you know what I
mean actually live and breathe what
you're doing that's the way to break
through yeah and I think it's finding
the angle that you can bring a
perspective to their audience you know
yes for me with Tim and Darrell they
both knew YouTube way better than I did
at the time but I said hey I have a
venture capital background I have an
entrepreneurship
background can I bring some of that to
help your audience yeah that's a cool
idea
so you're contributing and I knew that
because I'm a fan of their right content
as well right right right right yeah if
you can send a template you're doing it
wrong do you know what I mean like it's
like I say my relationship with
influencers should be like if I'm asking
them to promote something of mine it
should be like we're as familiar as like
me asking them to like water my plants
while I'm out of town like that's the
kind of relationship that I want to have
where I've done things for them and then
so if I'm asking something of them they
don't they don't feel like that's an
imposition they feel like this is what
we do for each other right how do you
how do you maintain the relationships
with all the people that you kind of
want to stay in touch with cuz I think
about we work together like way back
when you were part of American Apparel
and a small project together and then
and then you know we lost touch yeah
great at staying in touch and you shot
me an email say hey Evan I forget what
you're working on like hey favorite in
town I love to meet and then we
connected in New York and yeah reconnect
it but it's like years later like so I
imagine you multiply that over how many
people who have influenced like how do
you how do you maintain those
relationships I'm not as good at as good
at it as some people or as I could be
certainly like like when I saw when we
reconnected it was literally like I was
just watching videos on YouTube and I
was like I remember this dude we talked
like eight years ago and and but but I
think the difference is as soon as I as
soon as I had that reaction I didn't go
like hey I should say something to him I
I said something to you know what I mean
like I sent you an email like right then
and and like part of that though is that
I wasn't thinking like Oh what can I get
out of Evan it was like I'm gonna reach
out to this / - in that right so you
have to you actually have to love it
like if you're thinking about this like
transactionally i think it's not going
to be fun and you're not gonna do it
right like like that for instance
there's services like contactually and
other apps where like they sort of
monitor your email and they go like hey
you haven't sent Evan and you
six months like to send him a note and
like I get those from other people and I
can spot when they're doing it you know
like like I got this email out of the
blue from someone it was like hi Ryan I
just wanted to see how I could help you
today and like that was all it said I
was like no human would ever send this
email like that's such a weird thing to
say you know and and like so it just
made me feel like I was like a part of
that person's to-do list and I didn't
appreciate that so great
maybe my system isn't perfect but I do
feel like it's authentic and real and so
I kind of do it that applies to too much
more than just business relationships to
you like to your team to your family to
your friends I tried to get in that
habit to you like if I'm thinking about
somebody I can tell them and even
yesterday as an example or two years ago
I was in the shower thinking about
somebody on my team is it's a dude and I
brought them and said hey hey hey Jason
I was thinking about you in the shower
this morning lol and then they bit like
my thoughts yeah and like it's even more
authentic and more human and more funny
and I've never had those things backfire
and sometimes it's like 2:00 in the
morning just this random thought like
I'm thinking about Ryan I'm thinking
about somebody and you just shoot out
that email should have that message
right away because you're gonna forget
the next day and you're also in that
authentic moment thinking about them so
the weirdest thing happened to me when I
wrote this book called the obstacles the
way and as after it came out it started
to make its way through professional
sports sort of a total accident I didn't
plan it I didn't know it and it was the
weirdest thing I started getting emails
from like coaches like big coaches for
big teams like the New England Patriots
and the Seahawks and stuff like that and
and at first I was like shocked like I
was like why are these people emailing
me this makes like it's cool that
they're reading my book but why are they
emailing me and then I realized that
they had the same habit that you and I
were just talking about if they read
something and they liked it they shot
the person an email and so and and
that's how they've built up really
valuable networks of experts and allies
and donors and supporters and reporters
and all these things right it's like
they if they see something they like so
so that's a habit that I've tried to
cultivate like if I'm reading
an article in The New York Times and I
think it's really good I'll shoot the
reporter an email I'll just be like hey
look I thought this was really good I'm
like they don't I don't say like hey you
know I have a big email list we should
be friends or something like I just send
them this note and then who knows maybe
in seven years I'll be watching the
YouTube video and I'll be like hey
remember we talked seven years ago and
we should do something you know like you
might you you the really these things
aren't so transactional they're like
little investments little bets you know
and and you never know how things are
gonna turn out and so I think you want
to be as generous and friendly and
authentic as possible you know Brian
Grazer yes the the filmmaker yeah yeah
so something I don't know am i'm a huge
fan but he said behind the scenes guy
right like he's with the matching
entertainment Ron Howard they've won
like you know dozens of Academy Awards a
path you know that so his team reached
out to me and said hey Brian would like
to meet you really come to LA and and
have a half an hour sit down with Brian
it's like okay sure happy to go down
there I had something else happening
there so I popped in and he explained to
me that you know he liked my channel he
shows his son the videos and he just
wanted to meet he's like I don't know I
don't know what to talk about yeah I
have no agenda yeah when I came to
Hollywood I knew nobody and I just met
people and said hey I'm curious about
you and now he kind of knows everyone in
Hollywood he's expanding beyond to other
creatives and there's no agenda just to
meet and connect basically do you ever
want to do a TV short movie and like I
don't know I'm gonna write so like that
curiosity that reaching out that forming
connections with no agenda is
interesting ya know and and I'm from
what I've read about Brian graders some
of his biggest movies have come from
lunches like that you know like I think
that he met Eminem that way and that's
how the movie 8 mile happened you know
it's like he would meet interesting
people who's it's like you you have to
have that flicker of interest and then
you have to pursue it and I think a lot
of people just sort of leave things on
the table that way
interesting well Brian is crazy how
quickly time flies really at the mark I
want everybody to check out perennial
cellar check it on an amazon go to
perennial sale calm I'm going to give it
to Ryan for one final message Ryan my
grandkid
is gonna watch this video I'm gonna make
her go to this part in the video let's
start with what's the final message you
want to deliver to people that my grand
my granddaughter's gonna watch so so
here's what I would say I think there's
lots of ways to make money in life right
you can make money on Wall Street you
can make money as an entrepreneur you
can make there's lots of ways to make
money and some of the money some of
those ways are surprisingly easy right
and I think we we actually make it seem
harder than it actually is
so my point is if you're gonna if you're
gonna make art right you're gonna make
videos or books or you're gonna be a
writer or you're gonna be a creator of
some kind don't do it just to make money
do it because you want to make something
meaningful and important because you
want to leave a legacy because you want
something that can last for more than
one generation right and so if you're
gonna do it I would say do it right
right like don't don't decide to be an
author because you heard lots of people
are making money in ebooks that's a
really crummy reason to do it do it
because you can't not do it because it
speaks to some part of your soul and I
think you'll be you'll not only be
happier but I actually think you'll be a
lot more successful I love it
Ryan holiday ladies and gentlemen well
right thank you for your time thank you
guys all for watching we'll do this
again soon we believe in you hope
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is Thank You
Ryan we'll see you soon